okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i
have a special guest on the channel a
billionaire matchmaker how cool is that
welcome gina hendrix thank you for
coming yay thanks for having me i
appreciate it
thank you guys before we start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos guys if you have watched two or
more of my labs lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay like beef so
hit that subscribe button what does beef
mean what does that mean
oh beef is like um
we got issues like we got oh beef like
we're gonna fight like we got it yeah
yeah i got it i'm like
i'm like super tough so like they're
they're totally scared
okay so tell me
a little bit about how you got into
matchmaking um as i was saying
off-camera a little bit guys
i promise you i know you guys are always
skeptical of women that give dating
advice okay you guys are always
skeptical and i agree with you
90 of the time
but gina knows what she's talking about
i she is so level head headed and the
stuff she says is very honest and to the
point so tell me how you got into
matchmaking for billionaires real i was
telling you you know like i've been i
think
the reason that my information is
spot on if you will and and uh and good
and great you know because i
authentically and down in the trenches
like you know i i was saying to you you
know it's not like oh i found my one
person in the whole world i think it's
just when somebody wants to capitalize
and make a business out of finding their
one person or taking some sort of
relationship course and now they're
going to show you
i i just wouldn't lean hard on that
because i've dealt with thousands and
thousands of personalities matching them
and seeing behind the scenes and that's
what gives me the insight and as far and
also being a young lady at one time
making all the mistakes as well so
anyway so i got into this because of
that reason i was you know young and
naive and i moved to l.a and i dated all
the bad boys um at celebrities you know
movie star whatever you name it and uh
and i made all the mistakes um until i
started this business so i was one of
these women who was obsessed with love
and dating obsessed with talking about
it obsessed with reading books and and i
but i'd always also been a good
connector i just love connecting people
with good things like people with events
people with jobs people with animals
whatever um people with people so anyway
so in the early 2000s i i was a
celebrity stylist for 10 years and then
um i just i wanted something more
meaningful i wanted something different
i wanted something that was mine and so
i i tried to start an online dating site
for several years when i discovered that
um that was in the very early days of of
onlinedatingmatch.com and all that and
then a friend said gina you know you i
think you should just be an actual
private matchmaker instead of trying to
start like a tech company because that
was so big and i had no idea um so i
started the business did not know what i
was doing just was like
working with anybody trying to help
everybody and then slowly as i went
along i realized that
it was a much better business for so
many reasons that we can get into if you
want to later on um to work with very
high net worth
men because it's only been clients i
only work with a few and then i know
them very well it's an actual
authentically private personal
matchmaking service and
it's just a better it's just a better
business i'm able to really give them
the actual
service um and the matchmaking that they
actually need and want so you know i
keep my business small and personal and
there you go
so
so i what are these guys like like i
don't really know any billionaires
so i'm so nosy i'm like what like what
could a billionaire match me like
billionaire possibly be looking for in a
wife right everything um so i think that
you know first of all there's a few
myths like i think people initially
think like oh well why would uh you know
a high-profile
billionaire or you know i don't just
work with billionaires but certainly
multi-millionaires some celebrities um
why would they need a matchmaker you
know i think we all we kind of
immediately think oh like he must be
like a loser or troll and um and my guys
are not that's why
you know when i don't have to work with
many i can i can afford to turn those
down that might be trolls or gross or
women aren't going to like so my clients
right now the youngest is 25
and then it's 28 and then it's 34
and then it goes up and i only work with
seven to eight clients so it's a it's a
range but i do have
some younger ones right now which is
interesting and um they most of the time
they've gone to ivy league schools um
they are either self-made or they come
from really great families and they've
actually branched out on their own and
developed their own
business outside of the family business
um but you know essentially what they're
looking for is is someone who can
go to
political fundraisers with them can can
attend like like my younger guy he hosts
these 30 un under 30 entrepreneur events
and he says you know gina i do it you
know with just men you know just like
young guys but i would love to do like a
couples if i had the right partner so
then obviously she needs to be smart she
needs to you know listen everybody
listen everybody wants the prettiest
most attractive person they can get
obviously these guys are usually always
super fit they i make sure that my guys
are very cute or i won't work with them
because
otherwise it's like then i have then i
have to talk women into going out with
them and or those women just want the
money and i don't want to do either of
those things so i'm representing a great
good looking guy who just needs me to
sort of be the gatekeeper to make sure
that the woman is legit that she fits
everything he's looking for and then i
put my seal of approval and set him up
on a date
oh that's so that's so interesting that
you said educated because um in the
space of youtube that i'm in um
they they make it seem very much like
men don't really care about a woman's
education or money have you found that
to be true i think it is true if he does
not have an education or if he does not
have money or
if let's pretend he has an education and
money but he won't care about your
education or your success or or your
goals if he just wants to waste your
time
just dating you
so they'll definitely
but when it comes to marriage and
long-term relationships if a guy is
actually substantial looking for a real
relationship and truly smart and
successful and educated has all those
things you definitely definitely wants
that in a partner so it's interesting
because that's what i've
was my feeling too because i don't come
from a billionaire family but i don't i
don't know if you know i have nine
siblings and my dad's like he's he's
probably
what i saw that in your profile yeah so
and i'm um
like my dad's like a top one percent
like two percent earner not a
billionaire but he's very successful
and my brothers um
well they're not they're not nearly as
successful as him or on that level but
they look for like like my brother's an
engineer and he's dating an engineer and
they're like they very much wanted
someone that was on their intellectual
level but that's something that
the the space of youtube i'm in seems to
really not think exists at all so it's
interesting hearing from the horse's
mouth sorry
um 100
and these are things i didn't know
before i was in this business you know i
i didn't come for money i you know my
mom was divorced from my dad when when i
was six months old and you know and so i
i didn't know these things either um but
now after working with these kind of
guys and all these years all kinds all
age ranges but consistently
i find that if he is successful and
accomplished
as long as he's not just playing around
if he's just playing around then he
doesn't care he'll take it yeah
girl whatever
yeah furious and he's legit then he
wants somebody serious and legit for
sure 100 and the family cares like your
family i would imagine that your family
cares
yes yes
yeah my um
my brother told me um
that he has turned down girls because he
felt like their
education wasn't like high enough for
him so
yeah
yeah so he like this this kind of sounds
bad it's just honest though like he
wouldn't
he wouldn't date education majors
because he just felt like that wasn't a
challenging enough major
and so he really only wanted like math
science engineering technology
yeah um they really don't think guy is
serious about a relationship he
definitely wants a woman who is his
intellectual equal for sure yeah
yeah and gorgeous and everything else
but yeah yeah
well of course those guys can get it
right they deserve it if they're if
they're this successful right
this is why i switched to just working
with those kind of guys because honestly
even the broke jokes want supermodels
and it's like there's a disconnect there
you know what i mean so he's broken down
like hunchback like they want
supermodels too but ooh i would never
want to work with them
so um one thing that
i was surprised about was you said on
tick tock that they these guys are
actually on dating apps
some of them are yeah for sure some of
them are i wish they weren't like i wish
some of my guys weren't on the dating
apps
uh because i'm like you know i'm just
representing you so don't be out there
um
and and not
and some aren't some aren't but um yes i
know like my younger client he goes on
and off hinge um i know my other client
he was saying he was gonna maybe check
out hinge or raya but i was like no
although my client yesterday that that
has been on hinge at times he said you
know gene he's
so smart and he's and he's the younger
one not the 25 but the 28 year old he's
like and he's so smart i wish i was this
smart he's like you know gina
uh and he's cute and he does water polo
and kite surfing so you know but he's
also like brainy so he's like he
calculates things and he says you know
you could work
uh eight hours a day
and go out with ten women
on hinge that and maybe get one that
meets what you're looking for versus
somebody working with you and you know
right away you're setting them up right
on the money out of the gate with every
person you set them up with is right on
the money you know what i mean so
uh so they do do the apps but you know
it not all of them and some of them and
yeah so but but whether they're working
with me or not those guys and i know a
lot of them i've seen them i recognize
them they're absolutely on the apps for
sure
what what do those guys look for
outside of them i know you said
education is there anything else that
they talk about ridiculously beautiful
right
every guy like any and every guy even
like you know
you're you're no no offense to auto
mechanics but your tow truck or whatever
they all want super beautiful but just
like the ladies want super handsome so
you know what i mean like it really goes
both ways the women are very picky as
well but um
i'm in the picky business i say but um
well that's something you're you're
honest about they want yes they want
beautiful they want fit they want smart
they also want somebody who's
interesting
so you know i've said i've set clients
up in the past with like you know
someone who's just beautiful and maybe i
thought she was smart i could have a
conversation with her but they're like
she just has nothing to talk about like
when you go on a date they don't keep up
with current events or they're not
really they're just sort of some girls
turn into like you know
especially if they're beautiful they're
just hopping from party to party from
from event to event
don't really have any depth and so the
guys absolutely have to have that in
order for that to for her to become a
next level lady you know what i mean
and um what do you see because you
really get to hear both sides like you
hear from the women and the men
and you probably hear stuff that like no
one else will say on a public like
platform
a lot of the stuff i've heard from men
all these years is quite damaging i mean
i could never give the full full truth
um never because couldn't handle it i
can barely handle it
it's like they just tell me these things
and it's like you know anyway
wait so can i have a couple examples you
can water it down if you don't want to
no nothing
i mean other than them being really
picky um but then i you know again i
deal with the women too i mean
thank god not too often but once in a
while you know some of the women will
get into like telling me
some sex stuff like with with like
like with my client or whatever and this
was like an older client she was older
it's like nothing i ever wanted to hear
for god's sake but you know they tell me
things or they'll tell me if the sex
was not good and that would be a reason
why they wouldn't continue dating them
or
they just had nothing to talk about or
their breath was bad or
you know
or they were just too busy to date or
i've just heard it all i've heard it all
really yeah and what it's interesting
because you actually i like that you
are honest with women too because a lot
of times dating coaches will like
ah this is gonna kind of kiss girl's ass
a little bit
and and they'll be like because even you
just now when you said okay yeah men are
picky but so are women
yeah
yeah well yeah i mean listen i can't
help myself from being honest i you know
i think that you know especially like in
the because i do two things right so
private matchmaking for men and then i
do this coaching for with arming these
women with all the intel i have because
i do have this intel and i want to help
women beyond my private matchmaking but
i find that in the relationship coaching
space that you know most of these people
are just totally full of [ __ ] i mean
maybe they have good intentions because
i don't want to think that their their
total snake oil salesman but definitely
it's more of a game where they're they
know how and i suck at games i suck at
games i'm just too honest you know and
i'm gonna give you every help you need
and i'm not but when they play the game
they're only going to give you crumbs to
get you on the hook to sell you on their
stuff and the only way they're going to
get you down the rabbit holes by kissing
your ass and telling you so like one of
the things like listen i know matthew
hussey is really popular with
okay but i'm gonna go there for a second
so i've never met him i'll just say that
but i have gone down the rabbit hole of
some of the programs he has and i've
looked into it just to see what's going
on and i do you know listen let's hope
that that it's not totally game playing
but certainly when one of his big things
is he teaches women how to text the ex
or how to get the ex back text message
you can send to because women eat that
up
you know what i'm saying and that's
[ __ ]
there's nothing you can say that's going
to make a guy interested in you if he's
not interested he's not hot for you you
don't need if if he is hot for you you
don't need to figure out how to how to
say what to that's [ __ ] and
it pisses me off when they play games
with people and tell them what they want
to hear which is not really what's going
to help you you know what i mean
right and another thing like
that
like i just feel like a lot of dating
coaches it's never the fault of the
woman and it's always the met like they
never take accountability for like where
they're at in the dating
game does that make sense
you mean they you mean so you mean when
coaches are working with women they
never will point out the woman's faults
they're pointing out
because
that's business they're not really
because if you're really trying to help
people i had this talk with my assistant
joel who might be watching this but um
it's like she was like oh gosh i i hate
to because i said to her hey be honest
with me about this video i made or do i
look good enough or whatever it was and
she said well it's not really me to say
this but she gave me the critique i said
you got to be honest in order to help
people
i don't want you to sit there and tell
me you look great gina if i need to redo
the video and i don't look great you
know what i mean because
so yeah i don't believe in bullshitting
people at the same time i do know where
i can't go
there are things where i can't go
sometimes you know like i'll give you an
example because i have a i have two
private facebook groups one is called
badass brilliant women and that's where
it's just all things to elevate women to
to being their best selves and then i
have the great manhunt group on facebook
and that's just dating dating questions
are coming at me and i'll try to answer
as much as i can it's more of a support
group for women but um there was a woman
that posted in there they were talking
about the height of men you know and you
know what do you think this guy showed
up and he said he was five ten but he
showed up he hadn't been five seven or
whatever and this one woman said well
i'm tall and i always wear really high
heels on the date and usually when i
show up that's why they don't call me
again because i'm so tall okay
now what i think because i looked at her
facebook profile
heels i don't know that she's being
fully honest because a lot of her
pictures are filtered uh i don't know
that she's fully showing exactly what
she looks like so you know i think we go
into the world and we think we know the
reason and we want to believe it but i
don't
you know that's not always the real
reason and i would love to be totally
honest like that but like those are
things like i just have to kind of go
no
i'm i'm six foot so i have never had a
guy reject me on height like i think one
love the tall ladies the men love the
tall ladies so that is not the issue no
no no no and you were telling me also
that you play
volleyball which i was just talking
about because
in no way because i reviewed your
profile which we're going to look at in
a minute there's a big reveal coming
folks but in no way did you look that
tall
no pictures that i asked you to show me
or send me ever indicate volleyball and
that's a big deal like you need a
picture lobbying that so you see your
body but in an organic way you know what
i mean so i don't know those yeah so
that's that's what i was going to say
speaking of being honest um i want you
to tear apart my profile well okay i can
be really i can be as honest
i
i deal with comment sections so i have
pretty thick skin okay
i'll be okay um
so i also know that it's pictures
instagram not a strong suit of mine i'm
gonna just like be honest so
um this is my profile before yes this is
the one you sent me
yes
so
this is should i zoom out a little bit
is this sort of attention i would like
to zoom out a little bit okay okay
so they get the full effect here yes
oh okay cause you're you're don't yes
okay so this is what you sent me the
before
yes
so what
okay i have a problem with like a few
things if we want to just
yeah let's go
okay sure let's get into it so first of
all you look i mean this you okay
you listen you made
a lot of the mistakes that most people
make okay um so you didn't do anything
different than what i see constantly and
what that equates to is this is just a
very average girl's profile okay i would
say average to lower average profile um
just because you made some
quite a few mistakes which we'll discuss
um
so while you look kind of cute but but
if you're looking for like next level
extra guys this is not a photo that and
that ugly plate of food scroll down
[Laughter]
now again okay
go that deep but they're either going to
look at this and go you're cute enough
to move forward or you're not and it's
just like it's not elevated so let's go
to the next one next one my best dad
joke we'll talk about the info and stuff
later
right now
just pictures um
i go back up
go back up
above
oh above oh the info okay
well no
i want to see this telephone booth
picture oh i think that's on the left
isn't it oh no
i kept it because i like i didn't mind
that picture that's not okay
okay so this was fine i thought it was
cute it shows you're in london um now
okay i will
uh and that is that i i actually had no
problem with this info here about the
nine sibling siblings that was cute and
the phone book because you look cute
your body looks cute it's cute you know
okay i had no issue with it okay this
one now yeah you're 511 wow uh that one
is a nothing picture like that could be
me in that picture for god's sake
it could be a man in that picture with a
wig you're right you're right well why
even choose that photo you know what i'm
saying
i don't i thought
my outfit i guess you can't even really
see that oh you can't see anything
okay okay
um the next
okay so there you are with your dog you
show a lot with your dog and you'll
notice how i fixed all that and you're
talking to somebody who has a house full
of animals i've got four dogs and three
cats so i love my animals but um
but it's just you know that this picture
it had nothing to do when i when i
weeded it out had nothing to do with the
dog
uh that's just a sideline observation
that i had to crop your dog out of
almost all pictures when i fixed them
for you but i just don't think that
picture's great i mean that's like cute
send to your parents but not to like
have a guy go god i gotta meet that girl
yeah okay okay
yeah no um now this phrase let's stop on
this phrase for a second we will look at
the information what if i told you that
i'm recruiting people to come to my live
youtube show if you want to okay so many
mistakes here first of all
no guy wants to see that unless your
primary goal and this is what they're
going to think your primary goal is not
to meet someone but to recruit for your
show
so what is it
which is it
i will say i was like two birds one
stone but i could see in hindsight how
that wasn't
you need to pick a lane right right okay
fair enough yes troll for guests on
instagram or tick tock or wherever but
on a dating thing you know people are
leery of people anyway you know what i
mean they're like oh this chick just
wants people what a jackass you know
what i'm saying and
that's what they're thinking
no no i i could take it keep going keep
going handling what they are thinking
because i've heard it all and i also
would not give them the instagram
because i just i want to control the
photos they see because if they go to
your instagram and they see one
photo that makes them question error
then they're out of there so
i say you strategically pick the best
photos which we'll look at at the moment
what i did for you and this is me just
fixing your profile in five minutes i
just went as quick as i could so we
could do this
but um and in a perfect world i might
either have you do more photos whatever
but definitely take off the instagram
because you don't want them doing a deep
dive in your instagram okay
this is another before classic mistake
you never want to have a girl that's
potentially cuter than you in a picture
and i'm not saying she is cuter but it's
like a before and after because she's
got the makeup on you have no makeup on
it's just not it's not like a guy's
gonna go
why would a guy want to date you
just because you have a cute friend in
your photo
you know what i mean
yeah no no fair enough this is just not
this is like
just
i don't know just not a great photo for
a number of reasons now maybe you picked
because of the eiffel tower
um
i'm not big on pictures that much i
understand but you got to pick better
you got to be
your family you know what i mean
yeah um
i don't know why i picked that picture i
think it was just lower on my camera i
think people just don't put enough
effort i mean
yeah no you're right okay guys on the
ones i picked for you all right okay
so i think so i would like to see this
one
as your main photo now i know that and
that's why i want to talk about this too
i went through your instagram and i know
that
was this either a real picture or one
where you tweaked your hair like an app
thing
oh it um
no it wasn't a real picture it was a
filter to see what my hair would look
like look like brown and by the way love
it like this love it the darker i think
it looks spectacular
the so i should dye my hair brown is
what i'm hearing well i'm just saying
that that looks better if you're out
okay no no i
i could take it gina i could take it i
mean listen
even the comments on that picture were
great you know everybody
didn't they
yeah they did actually i think darker
like this it just looks great i think
you might have a little more makeup in
that picture too
yeah well i think there's a filter on
that filter's working for you
and even here's the thing even with your
personality and here doing the this
interview
you're cuter than a lot of these
pictures lead lead you to believe you
know what i mean now the first picture
you do
on the left the before you do look just
like that picture um
as i see this person here behind the mic
with her headphones on and everything
like that you know what i mean but i
think if you want a guy to stop and want
to learn more about you you want to
really choose the very very best picture
you can not just like oh it was a fun
night out i enjoyed this food let me
just you know you have to think what
you'd post to instagram and to friends
is totally different than how to market
yourself for dating you know yeah no you
you're telling me a lot of stuff i never
really thought about actually and i do a
lot of looking in and cropping and stuff
so again the second one i had no no
problem i have no issue with the second
one the telephone booth one it was cute
um it's fine you could keep it as is um
the second one i thought that was so
much cuter of you you could see your
body you look adorable i would love
rather than that i would love to see you
doing the volleyball thing
okay
i would love that but this is cute for
sure because guys want to see your body
they want to see what they're in for you
know although that picture does not make
you look tall like that is like but if
you were doing the volleyball where
you're like jumping up what do you call
it when you're hitting lobbying or
whatever the ball
uh yeah i would love a picture like that
okay
because then they're gonna go whoo cause
and that's just impressive i think
all right this one i had to crop out
your dog because it was a cute picture
of you and your dog but so cute of you
in fact you could even use this as your
main photo so again i want to stress i
did all this in like five minutes and
working with just a few you sent me
okay i spend you know a week with doing
this stuff or we'll look at things back
and forth but
just winging it i still think your
profile is totally elevated to a next
level and that you definitely attract
better guys this photo is adorable i
would be fine with you even making it
your first your first one
okay
no
read the comment is that the still that
youtube show auditioning
oh yeah
you're gonna change that
okay
i think you won't you wanna i think
we'll talk about info in a
and minute that i picked that other this
is great of you i cropped it in a little
okay notice see how i cropped i yeah
it's great i cried i took this out only
because i was like 20 pounds heavier in
this picture well i cropped it you
notice
that's why i cropped it oh okay okay
because it was cute up here like i
thought all this was cute not that yeah
but it it just i liked it better cropped
like that in fact you could even crop it
a little more like just behind your
booty right there
okay you know what i mean
no yeah yeah this one's a little blurry
but i went with it i did not like that
pose you can even show the photo you
should show the photo you actually gave
me of this picture and you can see that
i popped it into this
let me see
um the picture before guys was
and you'll see how i
you can see what she gave me and how i
cropped it forgot to
these are the oh wait is this a
different one from team gina hold on
sorry
one of those two first
uh you know i'm gonna go to my set
because
there we go
um
oh wait this one
oh wait it was this one okay oh wait no
no the one above it was this one
okay
this was the other other picture
i made the decision to crop it in
and then there was a zoom out on this
one
i don't know if i can
okay
so
this is the picture in full scroll down
okay
and it just wasn't it's just i
it just not elevated quite i mean you're
a young
but it's just i don't know it's just it
wasn't
and it just almost looked like gonna be
part of a child pornography ring or
something i don't know i'm halfway
joking but it's not
because it's an innocent looking dress
and you look like you know from the
walton family but it's a little low cut
and you're bending over and it's just
not so that is why i thought it was cute
up your face
you though off part of your arm because
as a former stylist whenever you're
gonna pose sleeveless this is just a
styling trick you never want your arm
flat against you because it goes like
that yeah
it out just a little bit so when i
cropped it in i actually cropped part of
your arm there on the side too yeah
well this is the same issue as i was
heavier in this picture like i was like
20 pounds heavier okay
see i cropped it yeah yeah so heat of
your face you know
yeah
yeah do you have any other any other
comments on this
um any other mistakes that i made you
can draw well no you know no friends in
your photo you had so many dog pictures
and the dog is fine but there's no guy
that's going to date you because of the
dog you know what i mean
um yeah i love my animals but it's it's
really the focus needs to be on you
okay your best you know what i mean and
if any and if you post a lot of these
photos are just typical generic
photos it's like it it is as if you just
sort of grabbed it from your camera roll
and added it without a lot of thought
you know and i think i tell everybody
it's like if in style magazine wanted to
do a spread on you right said send us
five or six pictures of you know what
represents you
these on the left that you originally
had would not make the grade you know
you wouldn't want them in a national
magazine to represent
so actually i have a question i always
go with like
photos that don't have a lot of makeup
because i don't want to like catfish
like i don't want a guy to ever meet me
what fair enough but couldn't you put
makeup on for a first date or you don't
you just don't wear makeup normally
um i don't wear a lot of makeup in
general um that's fine i probably would
on a first date but i'm just not very
i'm kind of a tomboy gina a little bit i
think so that i i don't think any of
these pictures are would would lead them
to believe you were anything but what
you are you know what i mean okay
i think they're all representative of
you you know i'm not a fan of like
filtering stuff at all
so or all the eyelashes and the makeup
so i never want anybody okay here's the
thing i never want anybody to to sh
to represent somebody that they're not
okay but i think at the same time
it you still need to shine as the very
best version of that you know i think
people are given options
uh the the down and dirty version of me
or the the highest elevated version of
me people go for that dirty version of
themselves and then go yeah this is good
to represent me to attract the very best
men on the dating apps
you need to flip no i don't know
you're absolutely right like everything
you're saying is true i appreciate it
like this is very helpful thank you so
now let me ask you did you go to london
because you're from chicago
yeah yes yes and you went to london for
the volleyball thing
yes
tell me about that
um so you get your masters and play
volleyball for a year so you're getting
your master's degree
i don't feel like that profile
makes you shine
in any way close to the fact that like
and what college are you going to
um university of east london
is that like a big deal
no
no
that doesn't matter you're still getting
your masters now where did you get your
bachelor's
um elmhurst college it's a very small um
school in chicago i played volleyball
basketball and i ran track there
wow all right there's so many
improvements you can make to your
profile i think that like what is your
ultimate passion this youtube stuff
um i like
music i like
youtube and i like sports what's your
ultimate career goal
youtube for sure
okay
so um but but i think at the same time
when you ramp it up about youtube and
your profile now is kind of about that
it makes you it doesn't make you sound
like a girl who
who is like sporty
and
athletic and has a volleyball
scholarship to a college of the uk
getting her master's degree
that
said is what you should be saying how
long okay okay
um i got here in october but i went home
for like a month and a half for
christmas so i think like maybe four or
five months total
so really your bio should be and even
when you're picking your prompts it
should be the part i just i tell
everybody listen don't go for all that
fluffy stuff because who cares about
that right it's like you're trying to
attract the best men and if the men are
trying to trust tr attract the best
women like cut the fluff and cut to the
chase like you know which is uh you
would do some create a prompt that that
prompts you to tell you about yourself
uh relocated to the uk a few months ago
loving life getting my master's degree
on a volleyball scholarship i mean that
is so much stronger you know what it is
like whoa these guys are going to be
like whoa okay now now you're legit you
know what i mean yeah
and for him i don't know what you're
looking for 100 but i can kind of guess
because it's usually a pretty much
standard thing which is you're looking
for a man who's probably looking for a
real relationship who's smart who's into
fitness and is is a little quirky and
funny am i right about that
yeah
gina you get me you're good at your job
i am good at this and
honest about it a bit um but uh yeah so
that's so you'd add you'd literally put
it there and to those people who want to
say oh the guys don't read the profiles
okay well the the guys that aren't
serious or you know those those guys
that we talked about earlier that are
legit looking for legit they do read the
profiles they do read the details it's
the jackasses that don't read the
profiles okay so if you can if you get a
jackass that comes along and it doesn't
seem like he read your profile boom he's
already told you he's a jackass move
throw him out and then go back to uh to
finding others you know what i mean
yeah
guy does care about that stuff so the
more out of the gate you know i would
even put because you did put nine
siblings but you didn't put like um you
know i'm from a really like something
and i would have to spend a little more
time on it but just winging it would be
like i'm from a really great family um
family is important to me uh i've you
know i
i'm
excited about this new adventure in the
uk on a volleyball scholarship getting
my master's program you know and then
throw in whatever else i wouldn't
mention the youtube stuff at that point
i don't think it's needed i think that's
something maybe you tell them on a call
and ann i do believe getting on a call
and i know you guys are young and
probably your audience is young but i do
believe in getting on a call because
it's just going to cut to the chase
you're going to see if there's any kind
of a vibe and texting doesn't tell you
if there's a vibe somebody could have a
oh
somebody could be catfishing in attack
call it's when [ __ ] gets a little more
real you know what i mean it's when you
can ask the hard questions so are you
living in your mother's basement so are
you looking for a real relationship so
or they said yeah
or whatever don't you want to find out
if they have a voice box or sound weird
before you meet them of course you do
yeah no i agree i've
always like preferred at least voice
notes or like a phone call before
because
like i don't
i i have a i kind of have a weird
schedule so i haven't really met many
people off of dating apps because i do
this night show where i'm like meeting
people like i have people here at night
um how often do you
no
three times a week wow
yeah like um yeah but it's like all the
dates that normally days that normal
people go on dates
well let me ask you a question do you
need to do it live
yeah um that's like what i think makes
it unique
um i don't have to but
because like comments coming in so it's
like i mean a live thing the good thing
about live is like people could ask
comments and blah blah you know yeah
yeah
um
because there's no difference in
recording this
because it's recorded live
yeah
live
well the biggest difference is donations
so like i was gonna say so like there's
a like right now i was going to read
this thank you for the super chat
captain cisco i end here
um i am a high value man and i want to
date her oh there are comments
yeah yeah there are well you're not
seeing it at all hang on why am i not
because i'm switched over to pipes
welcome to the world yeah
shit's getting real let me read this
stuff what are you people saying oh gosh
um
gina well then maybe you're a jackass i
don't know what oh i wouldn't sometimes
the comments
yeah this
what are you saying
no i was like sometimes i wouldn't spend
too much time reading comments because
they sometimes the internet's kind of
odd um
i don't read a lot of my tick tock
comments you know when my videos go
cuckoo for coco puffs and you guys can
find me at matchmaker at gina hendrix on
tick tock um but yeah i don't really
read a lot of the comments because you
have to take it with a grain of salt you
know what i mean yeah you could be in
sales actually i was thinking about the
way you like marketed like you just
switched that up like that was so that
was so good actually
what do you mean your profile yeah just
like the way you um it is sales you have
to think of it like that you're trying
to sell yourself yeah
and i've actually was thinking about
taking the youtube stuff off my profile
because i was thinking i was like that
has to be a red flag to a lot of guys
like you want to date a girl with a
microphone and a platform i'm like i
don't know i think
i just don't think it's necessary
i don't really think it's necessary for
your dating profile right
um okay so next question i have so i
hear a lot about
um we're gonna get to your book after
this this set of questions um
so i hear a lot of frustration from both
sides hilarious hold on now i know why
we weren't reading these comments let's
see
that's funny okay go ahead i'm sorry um
no no you're good so i hear a lot of
frustrations on both sides of the dating
market so i hear men that are very
frustrated by women that use them for
their time their resources
and i hear women that are frustrated
that they get used for their bodies
um
well
right
or they don't with the lack of
commitment i mean so they the guys get
the sex the lack of commitment or they
can't find a good guy listen i've
written two books one of my books my
first book's called stop being a [ __ ]
and get a boyfriend that's on amazon
i love that [ __ ] get a boyfriend that's
on amazon and then my other one's called
the great manhunt which we'll talk about
in a minute but uh one of the things i
do talk about in in that first book is
you know
you is is
women
make the mistake which i have made so
you know a lot of mistakes i've made
myself um but you know women think that
if they sleep with a guy that that's a
way of fast tracking him into a
relationship and we've all made those
mistakes and i tell women because when
they ask me when should i sleep with a
guy i say we'll sleep with him if you're
not going to get your feelings hurt if
it doesn't work out you know what i mean
so either in a conversation that you're
in a real relation if you need to be in
a real relationship then don't risk risk
it until you know that you're in a real
relationship but if you
sleep with him and he doesn't call you
again then sleep with him but if you
sleep with him you get your feelings
hurt when he's gone the next day then
then don't sleep with him mm-hmm
no i agree because it's kind of like
about accountability for the choices you
make so if you make that choice like you
can't get mad if it doesn't work out
yeah and i know that like a lot of times
like guys will say well i told her you
know i didn't want to be in a
relationship and a lot of times we don't
believe what these guys are telling us
you know what i mean but they they're
telling us the truth and you can also
put
put the you know
connect the dots by you know is he
calling you last minute is he treating
you like it's it's more of like just
sort of he's getting together with you
out of convenience or is he guy a guy
who's actually making effort like an
advanced plan right so it's like you
know a guy who who is seriously
interested in you they're going to ask
questions about you they're going to
want to know what your goals are what
your interest they're going to care
about you they're going to make advanced
plans with you but these guys that don't
act like they care about it or hey we're
getting together hanging out last minute
no effort if if it seems like he's low
effort then he's a low effort guy and
that really tells you what you need to
know and that's why i have that same
feeling too that a lot of girls that
like get very frustrated with men like
the guys tell them what they want they
just don't listen
would you agree with that
all the time yeah yeah women but it but
i think again it's also telling of a man
that is
actually authentically ready for a real
relationship
and cares about you and a man who's not
ready for a relationship and or doesn't
care about you you know what i mean i
don't think it's a generic blanket
statement that no men listen i think the
ones that listen are the ones that are a
little more evolved and care more and i
think the ones that don't listen
jackasses
do you think women like [ __ ]
i think that that's i know what the
comments are i think that
i think that women
don't want to be able to walk all over a
guy
yeah
they respect a guy who
who uh
respects himself and won't put up with
[ __ ]
but at the same time you know
i think the only people that are going
to get into relationships with like if a
guy gets in a relationship with a girl
who's a psycho for example and these
guys go i was dated a girl she was super
psycho it takes two to tango all right
it's it's
if you're not crazy you're not going to
get into a relationship with somebody
who's crazy it does take two to tango
and the same for the other way around
you know what i mean so it's like
if if a woman gets involved with a guy
that's an [ __ ] it's because she has
issues and he's going to end up saying
she was psycho he's going to she's going
to say he was an ad you know
it takes two to tango so i think two
people are healthy
they're not they're gonna want a healthy
partner you know yeah
so what is your
i'm interested do you know the 2080 rule
no i do not
okay so
if you ask oh yeah i just don't call it
that but
um it's basically that it's a very small
percentage of men sleeping with all of
the women so it's like 80 if you ask 80
of women what they want and a man they
list um some studies say 20
others say 10 5 of men
and like the the growing number of
virgins in the us is like for male
virgins is going up and up and up
indicating that like a smaller and
smaller percentage of men are sleeping
with more and more women
would you say that's true based on what
you've seen like does that match what
you've seen in the world
i you know and what age demographic or
the is the study
um that's a good question um i don't
know off the top of my head because what
i noticed with like my younger like okay
this is an interesting story that
happened recently so my youngest client
that's 25 and he went to
uh ivy league school and
he's like a major investor like he has
achieved more at 25 than elon musk did
at his age okay
and he's tall and he's good-looking and
all these things but he's also
you know 25. so i do think that a lot of
times when men are well when people even
celebrities this happens when you're
rich or famous you you you have a circle
of people that don't always tell you the
truth you know what i mean like what we
talked about people
want to hear because they want to stick
around with you they don't want you to
kick them out the door but with me they
pay me up front
and so they hire me
whatever i want like they can't people
what are they gonna do
so they don't keep me on a regular
retainer they pay me up front and then
we get to work but anyway so then i'm
working with him and i set him up with
this one girl and she was a little bit
older than him and a little more
sophisticated than him and that was good
for him because he's also very advanced
you know but at the same time i think
he's gone out with younger girls and so
younger girls
only know how a guy should treat them
based on the guys how how the other guys
they've dated have treated them and if a
woman has never yeah especially a
younger girl she's never dated a guy
that paid for her valet or walked her to
her car or opened her door and she's
just not going to know any better right
so he goes out with this girl that's a
little bit older and she's ridiculously
gorgeous and you know and sophisticated
and been around the block and she said
gina he picked me up from the date and
he's standing against the car looking
down at his phone filling on his phone
and he's looking hey hey how are you to
her and she's like he didn't open the
door for me he didn't like anything like
that
and so i ha and he really liked her um
so i had to give him that feedback and
initially he was like
what
that is what did he say that's that's oh
god he goes that's not on brand that's
not on brand at all gina and i was like
what he knows that's not on brand he
goes that is so pain that's such a
patriarchal
you know uh
thing to subscribe to and oh and he was
like disgusted at that feedback because
a nobody's given him that feedback it
wasn't he was to that as smart as he is
he's closest to the feedback and then
what he did was he went back to one of
his you know because he hangs in a very
sophisticated older crowd than him than
he is he went back to them and they must
have told him uh yeah man you open the
door for you don't keep on your phone
you know what i mean yeah and then he
changed his tune you know what i mean
but right like you only know
whatever you've been exposed to so these
younger girls he dated they didn't care
because they didn't know any better you
know
no that's it's interesting you say that
because i can um reiterate like
growing up in a family with money like
it can be very lonely because you have
to like you have to keep your circle
small
and a lot of times like i
it's so funny i understand exactly what
you're saying with like the people
around you like kissing
but to go but to go back to that
question that you were giving me about
the statistics and you know and this
stuff that reminds me of like when he
was like that is you know that's not on
brand and that's a patriarchal system
and i think that i can see that how how
the
how
the kids are these days you know with
gender fluid and you know and the the
pronouns and all this stuff i could see
how it would be turning more in terms of
younger people for sure that are waiting
longer to have sex um
and and maybe being more thoughtful
about it which would be a great thing no
the the data anyways
um it's actually that the of course like
the women i guess are having sex younger
oh but like it's the it's the mess so
it's like basically like
a small percentage of men having sex
with more women
so like basically this is this is the
percentage of
men so so so you're saying that the
majority is not like the most of the
guys these days are having sex with a
lot of women
no i'm saying that's not the majority
i'm saying like there's most women are
having sex with like the same guys like
for example a lot of girls say they want
a guy over six foot but that's only 15
of men and then if you add on like other
things it's like a smaller and smaller
percentage smaller right
yeah
and so i was just curious
when it comes to sex and i try i just
try to stay out of that lane because
that's you know yeah yeah if somebody
wants to come back and talk to me about
it and stuff and certainly you know i'll
tell the girls a lot of times like you
know you just want to take it slow you
want to because again i think a lot of
times women will leap into it if they
really like the guy wanting to kind of
fast track the relationship right but
that's not how a relationship's going to
be fast-tracked at all and i also say to
the women it's like if you want to stand
out as different then you have to be
different than all the other women he
dated and then especially when a guy's
like super rich or cute or sexy or
whatever that guy is used to getting his
way so if you want to stand out among
all the other women he hates then be
different than all the other ones
right
okay i'm gonna take a second and read
the super chats um thank you mgtow by
logic guys i appreciate you all the
super chats are going towards new
equipment as you guys know i'm getting a
new camera soon
and it's gonna it's gonna be like you're
gonna like see me it's gonna be real
clear okay
um okay so what does the man you want
want cater to that in your profile and
your life and your learning and your
actions don't cater to what quote
unquote men want
smart okay sam mendee musa um
help pearl get a date
great first step pearl also how can we
connect with you gina great show well
thanks that's nice um
well let's see find you can find me on
tick tock matchmaker gina hendrix you
can go to my website which is gina
hendricks.com
um i'm on instagram matchmaker gina
hendrix i i am going to be doing this
thing called manhunt mondays with the
ladies coming up that's april 25th um
you can rsvp to that um there's i have a
lot a lot of things cooking
her um her
social media is linked in the
description guys it's also if you follow
me on instagram i tagged her in my story
today so both of those are she's pretty
responsive so like she got back to me
or my assistant jewel will respond
absolutely
um you know
call with me if you have questions um
there's a lot of different ways that
that i can help you can always go to for
women if you go to thegreatmanhunt.com
you'll see the books i have you'll see
some uh like i have an a game course for
women how to bring your a game to date
these kind of a game guys i have a lot
of different offerings there
thegreatmanhunt.com
so um
tell me about your books you said you
have a book on
dating apps which is great because
my newest book is the great manholes
um
and that's on amazon and yeah so
basically in this book i literally lay
out it's sort of like
diy diy matchmaking for the dating apps
because
i've helped so many women who've hired
like these low-end matchmakers and then
they they give they take their money and
they don't really help them and it makes
me furious and so i coach these women on
what to say to get their money back from
these other matchmakers so i wrote this
book so that women can do it for
themselves using specifically this book
focuses on the dating apps because
i know for a fact they're there but
usually if the guys aren't doing well in
the dating apps if the girls aren't
doing well it comes back to one it comes
back to four things right four things
is one is your
photos aren't good enough your info
isn't good enough
the people you're swiping on aren't the
right people for you
your messaging is off you just don't
know how to cut to the chase quick
enough and then four you give up too
easy you delete the apps and then you
give up right you know you got to be
consistent with having great photos
picking the right people the messaging
and sticking on the app because they are
there they may not be there today they
may not be there tomorrow but next week
when you go on boom you connect with
somebody phenomenal so
um someone wants to know where did you
get your ideas
uh from i picking up which idea
um i guess on dating apps i'd imagine
it's years of experience yeah yeah i
mean listen i have been a matchmaker
since 2008.
i had
and i've studied the dating apps well it
was dating sites in the beginning in the
2000s uh i've i've studied them front
back and sideways i still study them i
keep up like i've spoken on panels at
tinder and other dating they'll call me
to speak i've been on entertainment
tonight and extra i'm just like i drank
the kool-aid and and i love this stuff i
even had my own dating app for a while
so i had my own dating app so i'm like
all in on this subject i i literally
talk to people
men and women about dating
every day
pretty much all day long from the time i
wake up to the time i go to bed and this
has been going on almost you know 15
years as a matchmaker but even before
that so
yeah i'm all in um okay so
someone else wants to know i like that
you're keeping it real gina can you
provide your top three tips for men on
their dating profile and if there are
any tweaks you should make depending on
the app i.e tinder tinder bumble or
hinge
so one thing i want to tell everybody is
that i have it's newish you know i get
so busy with everything else i'm doing
and
when i do a full profile makeover on
somebody it is time-consuming and the
more dramatic the transformation like if
you go so i have a youtube channel in uh
it's called dating app do-overs you can
either probably gina hendricks or the
show's called dating app do-overs it's
on youtube it's only a few episodes i've
done i've done some on guys some on
women um one the famous one that went
viral on tick tock they call him the
hitler guy i gave him a whole makeover
so you can see a lot of the
transformations that i've done
um on that dating app do-overs but um
but i would say men
you know same it's really no different
men or women you know i think that the
men just choose haphazard photos you
know whatever's on their camera roll and
they're not really putting a lot of
thought in i think you need to think
about who are you trying to attract you
know and if you're quirky and artsy then
make sure you look quirky and artsy but
the best quirky artsy version of you if
you're trying to attract affluent or the
hottest one you've gotta you've gotta
look the part to attract what you want
and if you're and the majority of people
are just posting these average low level
photos of themselves and it's not good
enough to stand out you know what i do
when i work with people and i help them
transform their profiles is i my goal is
to make them shine like a rock star if
you're on the think gaps and you're not
shining like a rock star then you're
just blending in with everybody else so
starts with your photos for men you
should put your occupation your
education if you're looking for a real
relationship there's nothing worse than
a man who's on the dating app and he
puts he doesn't know what he's looking
for it's like really you're a grown man
and you don't know what you're looking
for i'm
i just don't i don't
you know but i love her
so you know so i think you need to put
it what you're looking for and then i
think a lot of times you know
men sometimes are going for the wrong
women i mean it's like i've i've talked
to this one man and he was like he wrote
to me he was like all these women are
gold diggers all these women are
golden's and i was like what in the hell
is this guy got going on so i of course
i said let me see your profile
holy [ __ ] when i saw his profile he's
like an older man like in his 60s and
bless his heart he doesn't even have any
gold to dig for so i told him that
demographic's not coming for you the
gold digger so you don't have to worry
he was wearing an old shirt this was his
main dating photo okay and he's
wondering why he's struggling on the
apps he was in a disgusting bathroom
okay with like dirty tissues on the
floor wadded up on the counter i mean
like i can't unsee this it's so
disgusting the bathroom was gross the
door was dirty the counter was dirty he
he was suspenders
t-shirt i mean everything it was almost
like he thought it was a joke but it was
not a joke holy serious and he's in the
bathroom mirror thinking that he's going
to pull in the ladies with this kid
photo and it does not work that way
so you know yeah it's a problem
you got to wrap up your photos that's
really for me that's the number one
thing and for women a lot of times
especially if you're beautiful and all
your pictures are hot and sexy you're
also going to call in these all these
guys so men need to kind of look at it
like shooting fish in a barrel the men
want to uh need to optimize their photos
so that photos so they can attract the
women
as many as possible and then filter but
the women need to do the opposite the
women obviously want to elevate
themselves but then in the bio create a
profile so that it turns off the men
that you don't that shouldn't even be
knocking on your door in the first place
and i think on the dating app for women
they want to they use it like a
popularity contest and they want to
attract as many guys as possible and
then you can't possibly sift through all
that nonsense you know mm-hmm
no that's standards women really need to
raise their standards
no that's very true
their efforts and so on
um okay so
what is your advice for women how to i
know you've talked a little bit about it
but if you had to give
let's do three pieces of advice to men
on how to avoid being used for their
resources and women how to avoid being
used like for their body
yeah yeah
let me think about this so i i mean i
think
i think that
it's a fine line right in terms of the
men being used for their resources i
think that first of all there's nothing
worse than a guy who's walking through
the world with a chip on his shoulder
about that you know what i mean because
i do believe that you re you receive
what you believe right so if you're
walking around thinking there's no good
guys then you're going to continue to
meet no good guys if you're a guy who
believes that you're only attracting
gold diggers then you're just going to
attract gold diggers i absolutely
believe mindset is everything so i like
for my guys
um
they're not ever worried about getting
used for their resources because they're
trying to just date exceptional women
who are smart who have good jobs do you
know what i mean i mean if you're just
if you're just sifting through the trash
bin and just pulling out a piece of
trash then yeah i think you might have a
little worry about but even if you are a
little more discerning and you're
picking a woman who shows up with you
know something going on for herself
she's smart or she's creating a business
or she's living her life with like a
passion
then there's telltale signs if a girl's
showing up and she's just like doesn't
get back to you or treats you like [ __ ]
and wants you to just take her to nice
restaurants versus a woman who is
substantial and also has something to
bring to the table even if it's just her
intelligence and her taste you know what
i mean
so i don't know so that's the roundup
for the guys for the girls i would say
you know require these men to put in
profit proper effort effort which means
he's asking actual questions about you
he's acting interested you're not
leading him along if you're leading it
along and you're kind of trying to push
for dates or you're trying to jockey for
his time and attention and he just is
putting in very low level effort this is
not a guy you should be sleeping with in
the first place
hold on one last thing pearl yeah he's
putting in effort and he's whining you
and dining you but he's trying to rush
you into bed or putting you in a
position where you're not comfortable
and you say the word say i'm not
comfortable i want to take it slow and
he ignores that
again this is a guy you should not be
sleeping with all right he's not
listening to you
yeah you see you got you see how i like
her guys put it in the chat you see why
i like her
so much common sense just like dating
advice like it's just so refreshing to
hear
um 10 super chat from the actual king
smith did a reaction to one of your
videos the lady who demanded the 200k
ring it got a lot of views thank you for
the webcam fund oh i had a girl come on
my show and demand a two hundred
thousand dollar engagement ring
uh give me more backstory on this one
person
oh it was um i asked her like what she
looked for in a guy
who and who was she um
just this girl i met in like la
once it was like what does she do
um she runs a glitter company like a
glitter business
i mean listen i i i guess i would need
to really like do a deep dive into all
this but um i think
i could send it to you
yeah i'd love to see it did she get
engaged
no she'd never had a boyfriend before
oh
oh yeah there's so much context here
that i'm missing that i would need to
know and so she's never had a boyfriend
and
then where does she come up with this
idea about the 200 000 engagement ring
oh i guess her friend got one but her
friend looks like a mott like i i don't
want to be
is this girl not cute not cute enough
for a 200 000 and gate like i i like i
would i was though at seven years
younger and i would say thinner more
attractive i wouldn't even ask for that
like
it just does it sounds weird to me
because like you know i think we think
things right privately like like you
know but i don't even sit around
you know thinking listen here's the
thing i know too much about men that
that these days i just work and i'm with
my animals right i told you that what i
know is like too much too much for me to
even ever deal with and and i'm gonna
lie and say it's probably been damaging
i say if i got if i wasn't [ __ ] up
when i got into this business i
certainly am now because i just know too
much it's why i'm good at the advice but
i want to go underground after i'm done
talking to you people you know what i'm
saying um but anyway but but i i think
it just shows a lack for her to say
about the 200 000 it shows a lack of
life experience like she like it just i
don't know it's i can't get my head
around it because it's just weird
no well that's what i was telling her
because i've um my dad he um
if my mom asked for that he would have
found a new wife
yeah of course i mean some it's just
it's it's something
i honestly can't get my head around only
because i don't i mean my guys have a
lot of money obviously since i work with
billionaires multi-millionaires and
celebrities they've got a lot of money
um
but i think if you have to demand
something like that
then
then something's off with you or the
type of men you're dating or there's
just something that's just not
because because there's no
i can't even fathom my guys getting
engaged to a woman that would put that
kind of a demand i mean whether my guys
did that or not they might do it they
might the ring might be way more than
that you know turn thousand maybe
honestly it's probably not even that
much to some of my guys but um but just
even coming up with a number is just
weird and shows
lack of sophistication
yeah that's what
that's what i felt like because i just i
was raised in different values so i just
i'm i'm from a wealthy family but my
dad's very cheap right so we're all
we're all a little bit
you know what kind of guy that girl
would get like a douchey rich guy but
like he probably is not even that rich
but he's like gonna be like the douchey
flashy gross guy like that's what she's
gonna end up with
yeah no i agree who said she's not even
hot enough for that so i don't know oh
no
um
this has been so fun i'm so glad i got
to interview you can you tell them where
they can find you
and
they can find where they can oh i'm
sorry go ahead nope and where they can
buy your books that's what it was sure
so um my books are on amazon um the
stopping a [ __ ] get a boyfriend and a
great manhunt they're on amazon um and
then they can find me on tick tock
matchmaker gina hendricks matchmaker
gina hendricks on instagram um if you're
a lady uh well if you go to instagram or
tick tock right now you can rsvp for my
upcoming event and it's free the great
manhunt it's where we spend two hours
and it's all ladies where we i i bring
like i'll have like guests like pearl
and a few other women during this time
i'll look at their profiles i'll tell
them what's wrong i'll tell them how to
optimize it there's a live q a with me
we even do a live swipe session so you
can connect your phone and your phone
screen appears here and we're swiping on
min together and i say here's why you
don't swipe on him here you know it's
really fun so we do that that's great
that's the manhunt mondays where we do
some man shopping um and talk about men
and how you can elevate your standards
so that's thegreatmanhunt.com too you
can go there and get everything you need
from me
and then men you know i don't i was
doing some coaching for men
trying to offer coaching but um but it
was just like such low-level men that
were coming in and they were like
complaining about women and they were
like really like women haters and it
grossed me out so i kind of stopped i
kind of put my coaching for men on a
back burner but i love coaching men so
if there are any guys that want me to
like do private coaching i'm totally
open to it as long as you're not a lady
hater
okay
that's that's funny because i
i know exactly what type of guy you're
talking about
there's a lot of them out there they've
gotten like this stupid male coaching
and you know and and it's like a lot of
times it's very misogynistic and
you know
and i even know a guy that went to one
of these guys it's like all about like
you know
it's sort of like mind tricks they play
on women and all this stuff and then he
ended up getting a lady from that advice
although i helped his profile but she
was like
hideous so hideous and like just
hideous like
so you can attract women with that
advice but be careful of what you end up
getting you know what i'm saying oh i
went to a pickup artist convention there
you go i like i just i'm nosy i wanted
to see what went on and it was just
stories women you get are the ones
you're going to want to end up tossing
back in the in the pond yeah you know
and then just to be clear as matchmaking
because matchmaking is my big primary
gig folks women can go to my website and
fill out a profile for me
ginahendricks.com um and then guys you
know i just work at a very very high
level and it's mostly referrals and i
only work with seven or eight clients
and my fee for matchmaking in case
you're curious starts at fifty thousand
that's limited introductions kind of in
the california area but if it's
international it goes up to a hundred
thousand so uh yeah i know that number's
big but it allows me to turn down those
guys i don't want to work with and keep
my company very very small so
okay the story and i'm sticking to it
okay well thank you so much for coming
on this was so fun i'm such a big fan so
this is actually really fun to do and
and send me your profile once you change
it i want to see i like to see the
the full transformations once they're
completed
okay i definitely will okay guys
let me let me make sure i read all the
super chats i did okay thank you guys so
much for watching as you guys know i am
trying to get to 30 000 subscribers in
the next month
so help a girl out hit that subscribe
button don't forget to like the video
leave a comment and i will talk to you
guys next time thanks for having me on
i'm embarrassed that i didn't know you
had all those comments because in my
window it was just set to private chat
so it was totally empty the whole time
now i feel like an old idiot